[Music]
solemn spot here at the Rick Nixon
library the resting place for President
Nixon there have been two new small
explosive eruptions at the summit of
kilauea volcano on Hawaii's Big Island
scientists their report and
near-continuous low-level ash emissions
and dangers from that and from the lava
being behind a new push for evacuations
their corresponding Jeff Paul is in
Hawaii tonight that can't be any more
Frank it's time to get out it's probably
past time to get out a dire warning for
some residents on the eastern side of
Hawaii's Big Island as lava flows are
moving faster crossing one major roadway
and threatening others the Hawaii County
is doing everything they can to get last
few holdouts in that particular area
evacuated as quickly as possible because
the situation could turn precarious
really fast well not too long ago you
could drive down this Highway but you
can see it is covered with lava that is
still hot and pushing out flames at this
point if you were on the other side of
this pile of lava you would need an
airlift
to get to safety there are also growing
concerns that lava could soon reach a
nearby geothermal plant it's already
seeped onto the edge of the property
sparking fears of a possible explosion
release of toxic steam while the plant
is far from the summit it's close to an
active fissure in the rift zone
crews have removed 50,000 gallons of
flammable liquid and are in the process
of quenching filling wells with cold
water it's not easy to predict where
it's going to go on what it's got to get
there laser lava haze is still a factor
on the island lava is hitting the ocean
creating corrosive plumes that contain
acid and tiny pieces of glass residents
saying what's scaring them most not
knowing what's next this is the yo-yo
effective of bad bad and then the next
day it's it's much better so I think
we're rolling with the punches but you
never know what's happening the White
National Guard is now prepping its fleet
of helicopters for rescue missions in
the event people become stranded Guard
members are on standby as lava flows
increase in speed and in size Brett Jeff
Paul live in Hawaii tonight Jeff thank
you